good morning this morning on our eye on
earth series we look at the effects of
climate change on one of italy's most
famous tourist destinations
lake como which is legendary for its
natural beauty is popular with
international visitors especially
americans i mean wouldn't you love to be
here right now
but here's the problem melting glaciers
surrounding the lake are threatening its
future
and hurting the local economy chris
lives say travel there to see the impact
chris good morning good morning lake
como's beauty is famous
the world over celebrated by the likes
of virgil
leonardo da vinci and yes george clooney
but while it's endured over the ages
it can't escape climate change
from its flawless natural wonders to the
glamorous hotels of bellagio
northern italy's lake como has long been
synonymous with
the high life but take a closer look at
water level and it's never been
this low this beauty isn't the only
thing that's stunning
the fact is i shouldn't even be able to
walk here but this year the water is
lower than it's ever
been in recorded history
in this period we don't have water from
from the rainfall or from the ice
melting
or snow melting geologist philippo
kemerlangi points out that white
gap that marks how much the water has
dropped
so more than three feet yes more than
stretch
that across these 56 square miles of
lake
and you get 4.6 billion gallons that
have vanished
enough to cause dangerous erosion even
rock slides
when the water recedes the mountain
starts to fall
yes because you don't have the water
that help to the rocks to stay
there water depletion is also killing
off the
fish these days the local government has
resorted to stocking the lake with fish
from nearby
farms but it's still a struggle for
local catchers says william cavadini
head of the local fishing association
directly from the lake of como the fish
level is around 50 percent
less than 10 years ago we already
lost the alborela was this small
fish and was very famous in the lake of
como
because it was full and now is
completely disappear
to understand why the water level is
going down
you have to climb up more than 11
thousand feet
to the philaria glacier that feeds the
lake with its runoff
but with global warming there's hardly
any glacier left
says geologist miquela comey who grew up
in that lodge near its base
i'm a baby is very big
and now what is the glacier since the
end of the 1800s
it's lost two-thirds of its mass he says
so this glacier loses
more than 20 feet every year yes he said
because
my my children cannot
walk on the glacier like than me 40
years ago
this is sad it's not alone
almost every glacier in the world is
melting at
record speed according to one study
threatening our water below the problem
starts in the mountains then in the
league and then
in the in the plane yeah
yeah you know everything is global
and keep in mind this is just one of
many lakes in the area facing the same
challenges
as our climate now changes in real time
right before our eyes for cbs this
morning chris livesay
lake como one of the world's most
beautiful places under threat
it really is i've been there before we
were on a boat my
favorite son favorite daughter and the
guy who's you know paddling you said
that's where george clooney lives over
there so i was very mature and said
hi george
[Laughter]
they were embarrassed both lighten up
and guess what george didn't come to the
window he didn't
it was surprising no but you know you
think about climate change you think
it's so gradual but yeah i think 20 feet
of a glacier
per year yeah when you look at that you
can't see it
yeah it's really startling